vous
mais où
eh bien bon soir des gones à l'actualité
internationale du jeu d'échecs se son
émission tout à fait particulière tout à
fait spéciale puisque conférence de
presse oblige grand prix du sénat nous
avons ce soir avec nous trois les trois
champions qui vont assister dans fun qui
vont participer donc à ce grand prix du
sénat est tout d'abord le mythique le
très grand le spectaculaire et le donc
le grand champion celui qui avait joué
contre bobby fischer en 1972 le fameux
championnat du monde
boris spassky donc bon soir maurice
bonsoir mes jeux voilà donc boris
spassky guette avec nous ce soir c'est
une grande joie d'accueillir on reçoit
aussi deux autres grands champions il ya
simplement à laisser shirov qui manquent
puisqu'il est en train d'arriver à paris
actuellement on a joué le lotier qui
avait participé au grand prix de
bordeaux construire stephen et donc
arnaud hauchard arnaud hauchard bonsoir
bonsoir voila donc avec ses trois
champions nous avons aussi un public qui
est un petit peu nombreuses dans notre
petit studio avec bertrand guyard alors
bon sens bertrand bonjour stéphane je
suis très très content parce qu'il ya du
monde dans le public
alors il ya des bonhommes public et je
crois qu'il y avait donc sûrs en
quelques questions pendant l'émission
concernant donc les champions concernant
ce grand prix du sénat voilà il ya
quelques journalistes et ils pourront
poser les quais toutes les questions
qu'ils veulent au champion alors je vais
m'adresser tout d'abord à joël lautier
je vais l'outil qui a participé aux
précédents grands prix diagonale grand
prix de bordeaux
quel effet ça fait donc presque mois
après de refaire un grand prix comme ça
à paris houcine un mois c'est pas
désagréable
il faut dire puisque surtout qu'à
bordeaux ce n'était pas trop mal passé
j'avais été en finale le match avec un
petit peu difficile contre michael adams
mais c'est à 100 c'est une formule qui
me convient très bien j'aime beaucoup ce
genre de ton art et et en plus c'est
assez exceptionnel d'avoir un cadre
comme le sénat donc j'espère que ce sera
un beau tournoi
alors nous avons aussi arnaud hauchard
arnaud c'est la première fois que tu
participes à un grand prix comme sa
grand public donc c'est à paris c'est
pas loin de tes terres aussi comment tu
te prêtait préparé pour cet événement
rien de particulier il se trouve que
souvent les semi rapides ont une
fâcheuse tendance à être mal organiser
tout ça là c'est vraiment le du tout au
tout sait on en passe carrément à la
catégorie supérieure
souvent ce sont les petits tournois
comme ça à la va-vite et ici on n'a pas
l'impression d'avoir une cadence rapide
donc on se sent comme si on allait faire
un tournoi de dix jours donc une grosse
préparation donc une grosse préparation
n'ont en rien de particulier je pas de
grosse préparation pour un pour une
cadence comme ça il faut pas non plus
tout axé sur l'ouverture donné qu à 25
minutes par joueur on va pas pas de
grosse préparation j'ai regardé un petit
peu quoi alors que je me tourne
maintenant vers boris alors boris ça
fait longtemps qu'on vous a pas vu jouer
un tournoi d'échecs
arlette bourhis nous dit que ça fait
donc jouer le tutu conférant veut dire
donc ça fait huit mois huit mois que le
bourhis n'a pas joué
deux tournois le dernier tournant qu'il
a fait c'est un tournoi de vétérans
contre les dames
pour moi qui avais tu sais où ça a eu
lieu peut-être je sais pas quand j'étais
déjà entré dans aucun des deux
catégories
c'est possible qu'ils organisent une
énergie et je crois que vous aviez
participé aussi une participante et de
tiago immo par intel trophy organes de
joël donc boris considère comme un
outsider sur le sur le tournoi c'est ça
et donc ils se considèrent comme très
dangereux pour les autres mais je pense
pas qu'on le considère vraiment comme
comment notre serveur complet ici ou
quand quelqu'un était champion du monde
c'est un jour exceptionnel donc il faut
jouer extrêmement bien n'importe quel
jour on peut faire bertrand tu as
peut-être maintenant je vais m'adresser
au public est ce que quelqu'un veut
poser la première question toujours la
première question c'est difficile aussi
une forme de timidité mais peut-être
voilà monsieur relance le papa des lois
et à boris spassky malheureusement je la
pose en français est ce qu'il comprend
sa revanche joël lautier par rapport à
un tournoi ils manquent pas où il avait
perdu 6 l'occasion fait qu'ils se
rencontrent ensemble donc je le batte un
jour de noël et avoir dit que
il est évidemment si l'occasion se
présente il serait très heureux de
pouvoir prendre sa revanche mais il
n'est pas sûr de pouvoir le faire parce
que je jouais pense qu'il est aussi fort
que lui aujourd'hui donc ça va pas être
facile
je vois que tu confirmes tué diplomate
production alors je vais passer la
parole à madame boulogne bonjour voila
je voudrais savoir aujourd'hui il y a
plusieurs champions du monde est la
grande publique elle est complètement
désemparé je voudrais avoir votre
opinion sur le sujet est-ce qu'il faut
organiser en brèche un tournoi comment
sélectionner le meilleur joueur et est
ce qu'il faut le faire et des jetons
pour se former dans tout trop compliqué
cauris donc il va c'est assez compliqué
aujourd'hui et donc il n'a pas trop
d'idées là dessus joël non mais je pense
que c'est vrai que c'est un petit peu
dommage qu'on soit dans cette situation
mais pour l'instant on sait quand même
qu'il est le meilleur joueur du monde
c'est kasparov
je pense pas le seul à penser de cette
façon mais on n'a qu'un seul notre
championnat qui organise et où tout le
monde peut participer suivant un système
vraiment sportif c'est celui organisé
par la fidh est ce que kasparov
il nomme ses adversaires bon en plus les
matchs n'ont pas lieu donc c'est un
petit peu difficile de
si quelqu'un veut devenir le meilleur
joueur du monde actuellement il faut
qu'il parte kasparov et c'est impossible
de plus qu'on ne peut pas se qualifier
pour rien contre lui donc malgré tout je
pense qu'il faut respecter la victoire
d'alexandre le khalife môme qui a gagné
le seul champion du monde officiel qu'il
termine c'est donc ça c'était l'avis de
joël lautier arnould en question me
pince moi ça change pas vraiment ma
façon de vivre je vois des parties
d'échecs de bonne qualité et puis oui
mais ce qu est ce le fait qu'on ne sache
pas qu'elle ait vraiment un champion du
monde pour le grand public c'est vrai
que c'est l'idée ma passion la question
est là c'est pour le grand public
l'image est floue mais ma façon de
penser je me rends moi complètement
plaisir les gens qu'ils y pour qui c'est
important d'avoir un champion et un
titre officiel
en boxe ça n'a pas tué la boxe tout le
monde sait que tyson les plus forts puis
c'est tout nos prêts championnat du coup
je connais pas du tout la boxe mais nos
échecs ça ça gêne certains joueurs qui
justement sont proches de l'élite qui
voudrait quand même comme ils ont
beaucoup travaillé
revendiquer le titre de champion mais
c'est pas mon problème mais peut-être
que ça peut les gêner effectivement
voilà je crois que reprenait la question
peut-être une autre question le dessert
la public marina une jeune joueuse
d'échecs
selon quels critères on vous ai choisi
pour sa tournoi donc je vais peut-être
répondants est simplement c'est par
invitation on a choisi par invitation on
a choisi trois grands champions il y
avait une des conditions qu'on fait dans
l'échec dans le tournoi d'échecs on
organise la pour l'émission diagonale
notamment celui de bordeaux une des
conditions c'est d'avoir un joueur du
top 10 donc on avait même que la dame a
bordeaux on alexei shirov ici à paris
ensuite il faut deux grands champions et
cette année on a la chance d'avoir bon
mais joël lautier déjà qu'ils étaient
présents à bord deux cas accepter aussi
de faire le grand prix du sénat ce qui
est la chance d'avoir numéro un français
s'est pas c'est pas facile parce qu'ils
jouent pas très souvent en france joël
tu peux confirmer c'est dangereux c'est
vrai mais ça change un petit peu c'est
dans les années et ça me fait plaisir
donc voilà ça c'était pas évident
ensuite d'avoir boris spassky ça c'est
une chance
et incroyable qu'on a eue grâce à arnaud
hauchard on peut dire parce que c'est à
maurice c'est en tout cas pris son
téléphone il nous manque qu'un quatrième
joueur on a visité on a eu à vivre on a
une possibilité d'avoir victor
cochonneries on avait possédé
possibilités et arnaud hauchard appelé
boris spassky qui avait dit tout de
suite oui et donc on est très très
heureux d'avoir en plus de l'excellent
shirov de joël lautier et d' arnaud
hauchard donc boris spassky comme
légende vivante arnaud charrette un
autre coup de coeur c'était un des
grands maîtres en france qui font partie
de l'élite française comme à bordeaux on
avait fait signer qui est elle un peu la
star locale c'est la star locale
on peut dire qu'arnaud et la star un
petit peu de diagonale extrait pour ce
tournoi lui donne sa chance et puis il
est capable de faire un exploit comme
tout autre joueur donc voilà à peu près
comment s'est constituée une autre
question
alors peut-être si on n'a peut-être pas
d'autres questions va peut-être procéder
maintenant ce qui est important
maintenant dans cette cette présentation
du grand prix
donc je vous rappelle que ça a lieu
demain samedi à partir de 14h30 et
dimanche à partir de 10h30 donc demain
les deux demi-finales et dimanche 3e
place et finale on va procéder ce soir
au tirage au sort au tirage au sort qui
va être effectué donc par patricia je
vois s'avance je crois à bertrand donc
on va vous montrer voilà donc vers 38
avance pour ce tirage au sort on va vous
montrer donc on va lever cette coupe
voilà ça me la mettre sur la table à la
cool du sénat donc dedans il ya quatre
papier quatre noms de joueurs
les premiers tirs et les premiers
joueurs tirée jouera le premier match
demain lé second tiré le deuxième match
le premier joueur tire et pourra choisir
sa couleur
si le premier tiré par rapport à un
match et alexei shirov qui n'est pas là
ce soir on procédera à un an cette pièce
pour savoir s'il aura donc les blancs et
les noirs donc qu'on va tirer le premier
joueur donc là un gros suspense
voilà allauch arabe et arnaud hauchard
voilà donc arnaud hauchard donc
peut-être tu as tu veux atteindre son
opposant pour choisir ta couleur où tu
choisis tout de suite en couleurs de
pièces non mais j'attends mon opposant
jatoba les versets d'atteindre dans
l'adversaire et boris spassky alors
voilà première affiche donc on connaît
déjà un seconde aussi donc arnaud
hauchard contre boris spassky donc
arnaud tu as la chance de jouer contre
boris demain le premier match de ce
grand prix du sénat ont déjà quel effet
ça te fais moi mais je suis très honorée
et très fière de participer de façon à
ce grand temps - cd je suis fier de lui
jouer contre l'ol boris ou alexei mais
parce que tu particulièrement contre
boris parce que so british open to play
arnaud match non il est déjà sur les
paris sur des matches et donc alors on
l'a donc la question m'étonne arnaud
sais quelle couleur tu choisi de jouer
demain nous prônons riche choisir la
couleur à berne ont donc les tubes tout
schuss deux cas leur mentir quand il
ressort car je prends les belges les
belges c'est à dire les blancs les
belges du volume la première commencé
avec les noirs donc arnaud donc choisi
de jouer avec les noirs voilà bon c'est
décidé donc demain arnaud hauchard qui
va procéder maintenant il faut qu'on
tire leur deuxième
et oui faut tirer encore bertrand le
deuxième ouais ouais tu peux tu peux le
faire donc tirer maintenant pour savoir
lequel des deux joueurs est tirée en
premier pour avoir le choix de la
couleur
donc c'est alex et alexei shirov donc on
va vérifier que le dernier c'est bien
joué de lautier pour vérifier que vous
n'aviez pas d'embrouillés bien c'est
bien joël lautier donc on va donc tirer
au sort à la couleur puisque c'est le
soin qu'on avait fait donc si tu as une
pièce est ce que tu as une pièce sur toi
j'ai loupé le coche oasis on va dire à
jouer de choisir sa couleur
et puis enfin on doit dire pile ou face
pour voir éclore sur fil je choisis
bah non non non non parce qu'il faut il
faut que ça se fasse aussi relation et
la raison finalement faut que ça soit
tiré ils ont un fils blancs face à piles
blanc fasse mal pourquoi donc pile blanc
on va dire que ça s'efface
les bills et pis on va dire pied c'est
ça d'accord la couronne et face c'est ça
donc donc blanc pour ça non noir et
blanc profile donc blanc pour piles et
noir pour phase de tarnos tu peux
regarder c'est ce que c'est le poisson
ou est ce que c'est le
or comme elle est là et c'est donc je
lui n'ont donc donc les tu auras les
noirs donc tu auras les noirs contre
alexei shirov dans la deuxième demi
finale
dans la première partie de la première
partie avec toujours les noms dans la
première partie donc voilà donc on peut
peut être enlevé la coupe bertranne je
le fais tout c'est formidable donc voilà
les matches qui sont demain donc arnaud
hauchard contre boris spassky donc avec
arnaud qui aura les noirs dans la
première et ensuite jouer le lotier
contre alexei shirov avec joël lautier
qui joue avec les pièces noires dans la
première heure
est ce que c'est important d'avoir les
noirs et les blancs jouent elles dans la
première partie c'est une importance
toute relative puisque haute assemblée
de couleur dans chaque match mais bon
quand on part avec les noirs c'est un
peu plus difficile donc il vaut mieux
savoir qu'on a les blancs dans le
deuxième si jamais on doit encore
posséder d'égaliser au cas où le père de
la première on a les blancs et pau c'est
de forcer le résultat on a beau rideau
le fait qu'il est important to buy the
black or white hat veut absolument que
ce n est pas d'accord la couleur vocale
a remporté un titre
ok à redon bon si c'était important je
n'aurais pas laissé le soir un chef
horizons
voici donc c'est pas dans une importance
toute relative comme 10010 et joël c'est
à dire que bon on a plus de chance si on
doit absolument gagner avec les blancs
théoriquement de l'emporter si pas
parler ce qui risque de tout d'abord ici
là et il prend tous des informations
après donc je préfère me terrain
peut-être une autre question d'un
verdict
une autre question une question de
monsieur jean-claude moins une question
pour joël lautier
a priori c'est un c'est un très bon
tirage je jouais shirov demain et je
crois que tu as un score de +2 contre
lui donc est ce que c'est un avantage
dans
dans ce match à vrai dire je ne connais
pas du tout mon score contre un
excellent jeu c'est qu'on a joué au
moins au moins 35 parties peut-être plus
en comptant tous m'ont si tu as fait le
calcul ça doit être ça donc bah tant
mieux et tant mieux si c'est plus 2 mai
mais c'est sûr que le bon alex hayes est
très dangereux et comme c'est un
tournant par élimination bon c'est peu
difficile de l'inverser aussi aussi dur
de premier tour mais mais bon c'est pas
passé pas très important une autre
question d'un public non oui à la volée
scène que ce que les yeux un fond
derrière question pour boris boris vous
avez joué un match contre corps tenaille
à saint-pétersbourg en partie rapide et
ce match et elles ont une fenêtre
l'énergie alors à la question que je
vous pose c'est que vous avez l'air en
pleine forme
aujourd'hui est-ce que ce week-end vous
aurez de l'énergie pour pour un pour ce
grand prix puisque vous dites qu'il faut
bien joué que ça vient de là où est ce
que boris demain à de l'énergie avait
pas fait oublier une réponse ça je
préfère être tranquille et attend de
voir ce qui va se passer en fait
peut-être encore une question de gestion
de monsieur chabanon voilà donc je
voudrais poser de questions à arnaud
donc donc moi je demain je vais faire
des commentaires donc je voudrais juste
savoir si arnaud va assurer le spectacle
comme il a l'habitude de faire et je ne
sais pas si ce sera sur l'échiquier mais
je vais essayer d'assurer le spectacle
entouré
on l'attend a dit à des surprises or et
figues et bien sûr on pourra repasser la
cassette et j'espère des mimiques
extraordinaire ça mais sur la partie je
ne sais pas non je plaisante je vais
essayer de faire de mon mieux contre
boris ça dépend un peu de lui quoi en
fait s'il a envie de jouer des parties
intéressantes
moi je ne peux pas refuser d le combat
est ce que tu as un expérience du match
contre boris est ce que tu as déjà joué
contre lui pas du tout je crois que j'ai
fait c'était c'était une partie nulle
il est donc bon donc si tu pars tu pars
pas avec un désavantage
a priori tu pars sur une égalité quoi
toute façon j'ai abordé le tournoi sont
complexes mais depuis j'ai plutôt envie
j'aimerais bien gagner évidemment mais
surtout contre contre shirov parce qu'il
va céder quoi parce que c'est pas
vraiment quelqu'un que c'est une amie
déjà de bonnes de bonnes volées donc
j'avais je voulais montrer que
j'aimerais bien montrer que je peux
résister un peu contre j'ai quelque
chose à prouver contre eux contre les
deux autres joueurs aussi ils sont très
forts mais ces quelques particuliers
avec avec chiant parce que des envies de
voiture n'a pas été très tendre drôle il
avait envie de jouer au sirop fin de
finale où ils vont seulement pour un
troisième place en fin de mois là
exactement
donc j'espère que si je perds je vais le
battre à franchir offre à ses fans ses
passions mentor il faut expliquer de se
passer il n'y a pas vraiment d
élimination puisqu'il ya une grande
finale une petite finale
oui tout à fait il n'y a pas tout à fait
d'éliminer s'il n'y a pas d'émission
chaque joueur jouera deux matches donc
c'est le principe du grand prix ça
permet d'assurer un maximum de spectacle
alors peut-être une bonne question est
une question en tout cas de ma part pour
les joueurs ce qu'est ce que vous pensez
de ce type de tournoi donc comme ça
devant du public
l'ancienne avec des parties rapides
comme ça est ce que c'est parce que
c'est de ce type de tournoi qu'il faut
développer ou est ce que c'est le type
de championnat du monde qu'il faut faire
aussi avec comme le fait la fille d est
ce qu'elle est le mieux pour les échecs
est ce que l'om est mieux par rapport à
l'autre qu'est ce qu'elle est ce que
votre sentiment par rapport au type de
temps qu'on fait qu'on organise la mais
je pense que ces deux choses
complètement différentes
championnats du monde on s'occupe de
compétition pour déterminer mon en tout
cas sur une période donnée le meilleur
joueur du monde donc il faut un temps
assez long il faut beaucoup de joueurs
là c'est complètement différent on fait
un tournant pour du spectacle donc
partir de là on n'est pas obligé d'avoir
cassé par heure dans chaque sens là non
plus les joueurs changent et c'est
intéressant que justement il des joueurs
différents et ce à chaque fois et bien
sûr il faut qu'on joue devant un public
et que ce soit organisée de telle façon
à ce que le public puisse profiter des
partis donc c'est très bien
pardon quelle était la question quel est
si tu te trouvais l'intérêt que tu
trouvais de ce type de tournoi
spectaculaire par rapport aussi à des
tournois de plus deux parties longues
moi je suis pour qu'il y ait un maximum
de tournois donc semi rapides et partie
sérieuse compris quoi donc les deux pour
être pour toi sont son équivalence tous
viendront référent remettre le général
les joueurs préfèrent avoir plus de
temps pour faire de meilleur parti mais
pour le pour les spectateurs et puis
pour le spectacle c'est plus intéressant
les cadences rapides mais c'est clair
que les le niveau la qualité est parti
et quand même moindre dans les semi
rapides et maurice d'une finale jouée
avec la main ou par iata
d'accord je crois que c'était la réponse
est ce que bertrand est ce que tu as
d'autres questions et jeudi les
dernières questions
non je crois qu'on a ici à une petite
question via 2-2 question donc on va
d'abord je vais là la plus jeune des
juges est aux anges parce qu'on va pas
tous les jours l'occasion d'avoir
d'autres dossiers en champion ici je
voulais savoir si vous aviez même invité
une femme où vous avez considéré que des
hommes pour ce tournoi
alors oui dans une bonne question alors
par rapport au grand prix de bordeaux je
peux répondre le premier grand prix de
bordeaux on avait invité j'avais invité
sofia pour le gard donc j'étais déjà
invités défilent le problème c'est qu'à
très peu de filles dans les 100
meilleurs joueurs du monde il y en a
qu'une c'est judit polgar elle coûte
cher à éviter et donc c'est pas
forcément évident et d'éviter une femme
parce que bon mais d'abord en trouver
une qui soit assez forte
il y en a pas beaucoup et puis une qui
soit abordable financièrement aussi
donc pour ce tournoi on a pensé à judit
polgar mais peut-être on le fera pour
plus tard par contre on peut dire qu'on
a diffusé le match entre etienne bacrot
judit polgar qui a lu à bastia en
novembre dernier on l'a diffusée en
direct sur canal web qui est disponible
encore en différé donc on peut le suivre
on peut le regarder sur diagonale ce
match entre etienne bacrot judit polgar
donc on a aucun au contraire on est pour
tous qui ait plus de femmes dans les
échecs aime les échecs féminin ah oui
oui tout à fait d'ailleurs une autre
femme a posé une question et je me
permets à à poser les questions à
christophe autant qu'ils aient les
rédacteurs de la chaire de journal héros
tchèque
je voudrais savoir quelle est votre
opinion qu'est ce qu'il faut faire pour
porter les échecs dans l'écran public ce
qu'il faut organiser les spectacles
est-ce qu'il faut organiser
l'enseignement à l'école
est-ce que vous avez les aider comment
il faut développer les échecs
je sais pas si je peux faire une réponse
comme boris parce que c'est une question
très compliquée mais ce qui est clair
c'est que tournoi comme ça ça fait
parler d échec dans les journaux et moi
même étant journaliste je peux dire que
ça ne peut que faire du bien et est
donné des idées à des jeunes enfants je
peux simplement dire qu'il ya des bruits
c'est là ce soir et
il a indirectement et directement mais
aux échecs des centaines de milliers de
joueurs dans tous les pays du monde
grâce à son match en 1972 contre morizet
contre bobby fischer je crois que la
réponse elle est là ce match il a été
surmédiatisée en raison pour des raisons
que tout le monde connaît à partir du
moment où il ya on parle beaucoup des
échecs dans la presse que ce soit en
bien ou mal pour une raison ou pour une
autre pour un pot de yaourt ou parce que
kasparov fait ceci ou perd contre la
machine ça attire les gens et ça incite
les jeunes à rentrer dans les échecs
parce que le jeu d'échecs et fascinant
combien de fois vous avez vu des gens
des joueurs des maîtres qui m'ont dit
moi j'ai vu je suis rentré au les yeux
dans les échecs parce que j'ai vu les
échecs à la télévision je crois que
boris dit qu' il y joue pas pour le
public mais en fait il a joué pour le
public sans le savoir et je crois que le
public m'aime beaucoup
donc voilà la réponse est là je veux
dire on a une légende devant nous et
c'est ce tournoi au sénat dans un dans
un lieu aussi symbolique que le sénat ne
peut en plus que rehausser l'image du
jeu et sortir un petit peu le jeu de
l'ambiance un petit peu de des gymnases
et
de l'ambiance un petit peu flétri qu'il
peut avoir actuellement
merci de cette réponse j'ai un peu moins
vous poser une question
oui à boris spassky on voit pas souvent
donc on va en profiter
boris spassky ça fait une vingtaine
d'années que vous côtoyez les joueurs
d'échecs français à peu près quel regard
portez-vous sur le sur les progrès
accomplis et pensez vous que la france
est devenue une grande nation égyptienne
10 heures le complexo do so progress
sonic and the secret rings in good
possibilités des stocks de fabrique de
ce doute d'accord boris pense que
la france a fait beaucoup de progrès
donc dans les aidant les échecs et que
la multiplication des tournois
aujourd'hui est très bonne pour le
niveau général des échecs en france
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui je vois il ya
beaucoup de tournois qui sont organisés
en france un peu partout et qui se
multiplient un petit peu comme des
petits pains oui mais c'est vrai c'est
vrai que c'est important et c'est vrai
que tout ce qu'il manque un petit peu
encore scellé thomas pour les mélangeant
français efforts tournoi sans utiliser
tout à l'heure qu'il est que je ne vais
pas souvent en france c'est vrai que
nous venger de 1600 à peu près depuis je
sais pas depuis 6 ans environ 6 7 ans et
j'ai joué peut-être maximum dix tournois
ou vraiment jeu j'avais j'avais disons
les joueurs du tournoi réparer mon
niveau donc donc c'est vraiment très
rare mais je peux même moins que dis je
pense est bon il est bientôt là l'an
dernier à enghien y en aura probablement
l'année prochaine aussi en 2001 le
championnat de france est devenu
beaucoup plus fort donc ces deux
tournois dans lesquels j'ai le plaisir à
participer et j'espère qu'il y aura
d'autres moi parce qu'on a de plus en
plus de forgerie l'été je crois que ça
joue aussi au chocolat de paris cette
année je me sens absolument faux un
troisième voilà et
et donc à d'autres joueurs qui
s'approche des 2600 qui qui entre parmi
les 100 meilleurs joueurs du monde et en
plus on a un peu de dette extérieure
parce qu'il ya des joueurs qui
s'établissent en france comme la liste à
quatre chefs
donc je pense que maintenant c'est vrai
que c'est bien qu'on ait eu beaucoup de
temps dans un peu partout mais il
faudrait passer à l'étape supérieure
organisait des tournois vraiment très
fort pour les meilleurs joueurs d'accord
donc en complément des tons d'un
spectacle doit essayer d'organiser aussi
des tournois deux parties longues donc
cette fois réservé un peu un peu plus à
l'est parce que ça ne remplace pas les
on s'est difficilement passer ces temps
là c'est vraiment la confondant les
joueurs surtout quand ils sont jeunes il
faut des matches moi j'en ai lu mais
peut-être que d'autres nous avoir cette
chance des matches en six parties par
exemple ou aussi des tons à très fort en
baisse à manquer c'est quelque chose qui
existe dans land en espagne en allemagne
alors pourquoi pas en france
non je te vois qu'ils essaient était
d'accord avec c'est vrai en allemagne il
ya beaucoup de fortes au moins est fermé
pour des joueurs plus important entre
2005 et 2006 et l'opportunité de faire
beaucoup de temps on va fermer en france
il y aller c'est il ya donc près six
mois pour clore cet essai 6,7 cette
question donc en fait donc le niveau
général monte en france il ya beaucoup
de tournois les tournées spectacle
commence à se développer mais il
manquerait a maintenant quelques
tourments ferme et fort un peu plus
disant que ce qu'il ya aujourd'hui un
appareil aussi y ait beaucoup on devrais
je en espagne aussi il ya beaucoup de
thomas fort et peut-être on veut prendre
exemple sur l'espagne
parce que en fait si on regarde ce qui
se passe en france la fédération
française ait beaucoup des jeunes en
général en tout cas fait l'effet des
efforts c'est important et puis ensuite
il se passe plus rien c'est là qu'ils
vont partir du moment où les jeunes ya
plus de compétition pour eux quand ils
ont dépassé la junior donc ils ne
peuvent plus vraiment ramener une
médaille à la france on considère que la
presse évite se débrouiller tout seul et
là c'est difficile puisqu'il faut c'est
là que les vrais échecs commençait pas
c'est pas vraiment champion du monde
moins de 16 ans aux moins de 14 ans est
pas là combien va joueurs c'est plus
tard quand on devient grand maître et
qu'on affronte des joueurs qui sont
difficiles et là il n'y a pas
d'entraîneur pour l'émergence français
chacun un peu tout seul donc c'est un
peu difficile de progresser encore une
petite lacune donc au niveau de l'élite
française
stephen il ya des questions là alors les
cavernes public comment venir à
commencer par à vue oui je voudrais
demander aux trois joueurs qui sont là
charge aux l espace kit quelle tête
ferait il si demain puisque maintenant
la fédération française des échecs est
devenu sportive un émissaire notre
ministre des sports buffet venait avec
une petite plus raide pour vous fait
faire pipi dans une question sur
d'autres
nous félicitons doping prochaine donc
joël peut-être ne regardons que tu
penses du doping sylvain contrôle doping
demain je sais pas s'il ya des jours qui
prennent des choses mais ça doit pas ça
va pas fait beaucoup sur lui le problème
c'est qu'on sait même pas qu'elles sont
une substance qui aide vraiment rock cha
que dans le sport on sait on bon c'est
important d'augmenter la masse
musculaire et autres choses aux échecs
le cerveau il est comme il est on a
parlé du café peut-être qu'il y est
d'aller le café c'est pas non plus très
bon d'être hyper n'avons donc c'est
quelque chose
la fatigue on peut la combattre
éventuellement avec des médicaments ou
des doigts mais être plus et avoir un
cerveau plus plusieurs bons je ne sais
pas lire certaines drogues peut-être sur
le tenant au courant le moment dans
l'instant mais après on se fatiguer
davantage suppose qu'il n'est pas
vraiment de choses magnifiques donc ce
serait un sport c'est vrai qu'ils
seraient protégés du doping parce par sa
nature même en fait je pense que si on
fait du sport un conte s'entretient n'a
pas besoin on va pas s'effondrer dans un
tournoi mais ça c'est sûr que c'est le
meilleur remède
je pense pas que la drogue puis ça va
apporter quoi que ce soit pour sa part
parce que les substances chimiques à un
moment elle a fact
forcément les perceptions il faut quand
même talent clair c'est ça qui est
important pour bien joseph rester dans
l'esprit complètement ici ça détruit
lenovo thinkpad pas de pas de danse est
très mauvais pour les chèques vous
pensez qu'il ya pas de danger
à propos du doping mais le vrai danger
il est différent il échoit qui a une
histoire entre coeur karpov et kasparov
un moment d'idées et qu'il prenait des
choses je ne sais pas il ya des
histoires comme un délit comme ennemi
very good friends mairie quand même mais
jusqu au ghetto coralina que j'ai tant
que dj 500 arbres groupe proche d'al
qods et un bâtiment 13 17 900 taillefer
aux icônes de ce sport
d'un côté c'est quelque chose qui
compactent je suis pas si ça peut être
assimilée hockey
une autre expérience excuses de ces
expressions ne vous le devinez de l'audi
a dit qu'il ne pouvait pas jouer le
contre kasparov je voulais savoir
pourquoi est ce qu'il ya une raison
actuellement pourquoi ne pas se
qualifier pour kasparov c'est ce que
vous avez dit tout à l'heure
oui oui ce que je voulais dire c'est que
comme tu espères tu ne fais pas partie
de la fidh et qui organise le champion
du monde il est le seul
enfin organiser ses propres matches
la dernière fois qu'il a disputé un
match c'était en 95 s'ils avaient à ce
moment là une association de joueurs qui
depuis a périclité n'existe plus et
depuis ce moment là et on n'a aucun
moyen d'accéder à kasparov par des
matches de qualification puisqu'il n'y
en a pas tout simplement
et là le prochain match qui aura lieu
contre wladimir travnik c'est kasparov
qui a nommé krainik tout simplement
il a d'abord nommer un nom d'un mandat
refusé c'est on descend kramnik et
d'enrichir of oui ça c'était encore dans
le cadre d'un autre une autre
association donc bon pour un joueur qui
peut être pas numéro 2 et numéro 3 qui a
une chance hypothétique de le rencontrer
quelqu'un qui peut être dur une numéro
quelque chose comme ça c'est impossible
de jeu contre lui ta réponse à votre
question peut-être encore une question
en question y at il encore une question
donc on a non moi je crois que je crois
qu'on a à peu près fait toujours alors
donc on va rappeler peut-être on va
terminer là dessus on me rapport
appelait donc on va d'abord remercier
tous les joueurs d'être là ce soir vous
remercier encore une fois d'être là
évidemment rendez vous demain au sénat
donc on rappelle que donc la première
demi finale donc à partir de 15h donc
les portes ouvrent à 14h30 à partir de
15h la première demi finale donc sera
entre arnaud hauchard et boris spassky
avec arnaud shirt cependant les pièces
noires dans la première partie et donc
boris spassky des pièces blanches et la
deuxième demi finale qui aura lieu vers
17 heures fera s'affronter donc joël
lautier et à l'excellent issue of le
numéro 4 mondial qui ne viennent
d'arriver à paris
l'atout il ya quelques minutes donc il
n'était pas qui c'est pour ça qu'il
n'est pas là ce soir
donc je vois le lotier qu'on trouve
excessif à 17 heures demain et joël
lautier aura les pièces noires donc
voilà je vous dis donc rendez vous
demain sur canal web dans des gonades
peut-être dernier mot oui je voulais
surtout remercier le public parce qu'il
fait très chaud
repassez la parole cher stéphane voilà
donc et donc je vous donne rendez-vous
dans par la semaine prochaine mais à
demain puisque donc d'un terminal demain
le grand prix du sénat en direct sur
diagonale verra s'affronter tous ces
champions pour la victoire de ce grand
prix du sénat 2000 canal web banque
populaire
nous